how many times have you heard experts
tell you never compete competitions for
losers go find a monopoly and dominate
it or do this and do that and then
you'll hear people saying I love
competition I want to beat you I want to
see you lose all this other stuff so
who's right because this is a bipolar
relationship man they're polar opposites
who is right so today in this video I'm
going to give you some ideas and I don't
want or true them is going to click with
you depending on what phase your
business you're at your startup may be
mid size I don't know what you're doing
100 million 500 million maybe 600 maybe
you know in 60,000 a year but I want you
to be thinking about competition and
business in a complete different way and
by the time I'm done with the video and
I make my case to about competition I
want to hear your thoughts but
throughout the process if I say anything
that prompts a question comment on the
bottom by the way if you have not
subscribed to the channel be sure to
subscribe to the channel as well so
let's get right into it
look you have two enemies - enemies when
it comes down to competition right and
you have these these two competitors are
your main competitors you'll ever face
one of them is on the inside the other
one is on the outside let me explain
what I mean by this 90% of your time
ought to be focused on you looking at
ways you can improve you and your
company not what's going on the
marketplace 90% is here maybe 10% of the
time it's here let me explain when I
first started my own business and we
started up and we were expanding within
Northridge California right and I had
left and I started competing and I'm
just getting a ton of pressure from
competitors but at that time when I had
just left they were still emailing me
all their major private leadership
conference calls that work that they
were having that I could have gotten on
I had access to every single data that
they had at that time asked me how many
times I got on their conference call
this many times zero I never once got on
the conference call never once logged on
to the website why is that because I
knew my biggest enemy is this mind
getting distracted and the more I'm
spending time on the outside I can't
focus on how to improve because my move
is always predicated on their next move
and if I'm always predicated on their
next move I'm not setting the stage let
me explain to what I mean by this so
think about it this way if you're
watching this
and you know somebody wants to be an
English teacher let's just he go to
college to get a degree so I won't be an
English teacher awesome
what is your better place where you
going to have fewer competitors for you
to become an English teacher California
is it Chicago is it Texas is it Florida
or the Japan what do you think it's a
Germany can you imagine you from
California you get your degree and you
go to Japan I wanna start teaching
English here oh my gosh
absolutely come on down and American is
willing to leave everything behind to
come and be a teacher in Japan you have
no competition how many Americans ever
you want to go to Japan I teach English
how many want to leave American go to
Germany but that is the idea of
competition you're not fighting head-on
you know you'll hear cocky Joseph I'm
gonna fight you head-on and I'm gonna
kick your butt really even in fighting
the toughest guys in the world who fight
they don't fight it on for instance if
I'm a boxer if I'm a boxer and opponent
I'm fighting it's an MMA fight he's a
jujitsu expert my goal is to do a
stand-up fight because I can beat him
because he's fighting my fight his goal
is to get me on the ground because he
gets me on the ground I'm done I don't
have a true juice again he doesn't have
a boxing game so every time he comes I
got to push him up and get one in every
time I punch he's supposed to duck and
get my legs and get me down and then do
his stuff that he does submissions that
he does for me to tap out right but the
goal is for him to claim my game and his
goal is for me to play his game this is
why your number one focus ought to be on
the inside this is your biggest
competition you will ever face the more
you're focused on this the bigger the
chance you'll have so having said that
you may say okay pastor now what do I do
I mean I want to I want to build a
massive business I want to be all over
the place well it's in five things
you're going to be having to go through
number one is locally you compete
locally then you compete statewide then
you go regional then national then
globally
Andrew here his parents have a popcorn
company they make popcorn what's the
popcorn company called Andrew now are
you guys from Dallas or you guys from
Austin you're from Austin so watch this
how many a popcorn gourmet companies are
there in DFW right here twenty or thirty
how many and
Austan two or three and one of them is
who how's your business how's your
parents business doing great because
there's business that's coming in to
them because they don't have a lot of
competition right so locally you've got
to find a market locally that you can
compete with in a way that you
differentiate yourself from everybody
else a lot of times people already think
like oh I want to build a global
business you know I want to build a
national business yeah but you're not
even known locally let's focus here
first then let's go over here yeah yeah
but you don't understand look but my
product is a tangible product okay then
that's even more of a reason to start
locally because if it's tangible you
want to go global or national you got
inventory you got all this other stuff
well my product is intangible I can go
to another market yeah but does it have
regulations what's the state laws what
do you need to do code to another place
what's the speed of expansion so you
yourself I'm not giving you specific
direction I'm just telling this is an
area to be thinking about on how you're
going to differentiate yourself here
start up locally then you go all the
other stuff let the other guys focus on
going here fast and then they run out of
money or they're too thin it's like
going to war how many generals have you
read about when they would go to one
they have 10,000 soldiers and they would
say a thousand go here a thousand go
here a thousand goal here a thousand go
here a thousand go here right and they
stretch them in and all of a sudden they
lose seven at the fight they got 7,000
people they lost stay tight stay strong
go together and then take this market
and then go together and take that
market don't spread them too thin same
thing goes we wanted to compete a market
place now that's one part to be thinking
about next part to be thinking about
what area do you want to be competing
with that differentiate yourself that
others are not competing with for
instance price mine's going to be
cheaper okay great so I'm going to beat
him because I got a cheaper product what
if somebody comes and has a cheaper
product than you but I want to be even
cheaper what if somebody comes to see me
I want a cheaper you can't compete there
because MetroPCS we're gonna have the
cheapest one someone's always willing to
go cheaper if that's what you're going
to be fighting we're gonna have better
service that's actually good one if you
can do that and the service is so good
that I walk away remember in it I'm
telling the story to other people maybe
it's going to be experience right maybe
it's going to be quality of your product
it's just above everybody else maybe
it's the speed of delivery maybe it's
your marketing the way you tell story
this battle like Coca Cola's been
telling stories and maybe pepsi is right
you always feel good when you see koco's
their marketing is impeccable that some
will say what coca-cola takes a million
times better Pepsi case they have a very
good marketing McDonald spells good
marketing right some people is
regulation what do I mean by regulation
look one thing most people you know
sometimes they ask mean it's a kind of
lies why is this bigger company that's
worth this much and the guy's worth six
billion why is he giving money to the
person that's saying in a presidential
campaign that that person is going to
over regulate their industry why would
this guy give money to him this makes no
sense to me Pat it makes all the sense
in the world what do you mean because
he's given money to this guy with a way
for regulation to come out that helps
them so the barrier to enter is tougher
so you can't compete with them so the
bigger companies want more regulation so
you can't catch up to them anymore the
bigger companies the smaller guys that
are coming out they're like dude let's
get rid of regulation so I can compete
the bigger come sir no no no we're not
working that hard again man because we
build those business over regulate these
young guys so they can't catch up cuz we
know how hard it is give them more
regulation that's their competition
right so you got to figure out a way
it's going to get more regulated here
how am i planning myself to make sure
this is you're thinking about that as
well here's another thing to be thinking
about when it comes down to competitions
blue ocean strategy if you haven't read
the book you ought to read the book it
tells you four things
so look at your industry whatever
industry you're part of how can you
eliminate something that maybe other
competitors are doing just get rid of it
completely get rid of it you know what
these guys are selling motorcycles and
cars we're going to get rid of the cars
we're going to focus purely on
motorcycle greats you're eliminating
cars or everybody's focused on trucks or
all this other stuff we're going to get
rid of trucks we're going to focus on
vans because we're going after family
marque or whatever it is
eliminate we're going to increase a
certain part of the business we're going
to decrease market we're going to
decrease something right and part of the
business and then we're going to create
something that others are not doing and
this becomes your story that others
don't have
myspace had music Facebook doesn't have
music and they don't care whether you
like it or not they decrease and
eliminate this right
create a fanpage myspace didn't have
fanpage all of these things yahoo -
google yahoo had paris you know
horoscope and all this stuff google said
we don't care about horoscope we're
going to give you box they eliminated
everything this will never work they
eliminated but they made it simple
search what's easy they increase you
know ease your way for you to use it and
then boom they grew so you got to be
thinking about this as well in your own
industry whatever phase your business
you're at so again i'm thinking out loud
with you to give you some ideas that
some is going to connect with you next
study what's working and what's not
working there's something that's not
working in the marketplace study it what
is working what's not working project
future issues and opportunities i think
a lot of times people are so focused on
what's going on right now that they
forget what is going to be taking place
in next few years what new regulations
could possibly come out what's going to
happen some politically what are some
changes that's going to take place in
your state and your local area who's the
mayor get involved build a relationship
with some of these guys that are
involved in those areas maybe you can
say no in the future i think what's
going to happen technology this products
going to go away i really think that's
going to be going away technology's
really moving this way start making some
future projections yourself start
thinking about it what do you think is
going to happen here what do you think
is going to happen here so you're
thinking long term knowing how you can
pivot properly to be prepared for some
of those regulations and some of those
opportunities the simplest way for me is
to beat your prior best competition for
me it's been very simple it's to
constantly focus on beating your
privates you've heard me talk about this
many times if your number is $60,000 in
a month focus on beating 60k a month if
your number is nine months in a row
you're beating the prior best do ten
months if your number is four thursday
your biggest sale is six thousand
dollars for thursday beat $6,000 or
$7,000 if you can't see focus on that
part you're eventually going to be
increasing q next thing you know you're
competing with many of the people
outside and they're focused on you
because you've been focused on the
inside game know where you want to
compete and differentiate know where
your strong gatim or your weak at this
two part i said they head on and a
long-term thinking versus short-term
thinking so as you think about these
things with competition the more you can
position yourself where everybody else
is pivoting based on your moves you're
winning
the more you're positioning yourself or
your constipating on for instance I'll
give you an example right now with
basketball everybody in the NBA is
changing their teams to learn how to
face who Golden State right well what if
the team says I'm going to do it a
complete different way I'm going to
build around a massive Center and
defense and I'm going to shake them up
I'm playing a different game what if
that happens then someone's someone's
making them pivot to them if you keep
trying to pivot to the Golden State
you're not going to be winning so the
idea about everything I'm telling you
what competition is figure out a way to
go into a market where you're not
competing with everybody else figure out
a way to go into a market where you're
all by yourself and everybody is kind of
looking at you as the expert and you're
saying look do you guys are big but I'm
not competing with you I'm competing
with this and no one's in this space I'm
creating this space I'm doing this part
here I'm going after this market you
want to sell to these people I'm not
selling to them I'm selling over here
you you're looking for this age I'm
looking for this age you're looking for
this educational background I'm looking
for this and no one's paying attention
to them
the more you find that niche that part
that no one's going to you end up
creating your own opportunity that
nobody else is competing with as well in
that marketplace so that's what I would
tell you to be thinking about what
competition again it got questioned
thoughts comment on the bottom and if
you haven't subscribed yet click on the
subscribe button to see more videos on
bias and take everybody's provide
you
[Music]